- One thing that I'm really
starting to notice is that
it's becoming extremely
difficult not to spend all
of our time on social
media, on the internet
and all of that during
these times of isolation,
as if it wasn't already a huge problem.
And it kind of makes sense
when you think about it.
If people are locked inside
their houses all day long
then obviously they're
gonna start gravitating
towards these pleasure boxes,
these entertainment cubes.
And I don't wanna be another video
that's just like
smartphone bad, books good
but I do think that the growing influence
of these algorithm heavy
websites needs to be talked about
because the majority of
these websites or these apps
are designed from the ground up
to be as addictive as possible.
I just finished watching the documentary,
"The Social Dilemma" on Netflix,
and it really reminded me
of some of the things that I also read
in "Digital Minimalism" by Cal Newport.
And that is that for
these big tech companies
our attention is their currency.
We're not the customer, we're the product.
The customer of Facebook and Instagram
and whatever are the third-party companies
that have advertising on their platform.
And that gets advertised to us.
So it's in big tech's best interest
to keep us hooked on these
apps for as long as possible.
And that's why they're
so algorithm dependent
because there hasn't
been a tool in history
that has been so powerful at predicting
what you're going to do next.
What your likes and
what your dislikes are,
what videos you're most likely to binge,
what topics you're most interested in,
these websites are unbelievably good
at just serving you a video
that you're likely to watch
and that you're likely to
waste a lot of time on.
Maybe this video, this type
of self-improvement content
is something that you're likely to binge
which is why I ended up
on your YouTube homepage.
These algorithms are powerful.
And I don't wanna be all
doom and gloom about this.
I'm not saying that there's
nothing we can do about it,
but I think it is important to
be conscious of our behavior
because these apps rely so heavily
on our unconscious behavior.
So what's the solution?
It would probably be pretty
lonely if we just cut ourselves
off from technology altogether,
and then also just lived
in an empty house by ourselves for months
and months and months until
this whole thing blows over.
But at the same time we
do have to be proactive
with finding solutions I think.
Otherwise our internet use is
gonna get so out of control
and occupy like 90% of our day
and when the pandemic is actually over,
we're still gonna have this
habit of just waiting up
and going on the internet
for like 90% of the day
and then going to bed.
And I'm not sure if I have
the answer to this problem
because everybody's life is so different.
So I figured it'd be really
cool to talk to my friend
and fellow creator, Nathaniel
Drew about this issue
and try to get his thoughts
on maybe some solutions.
And hopefully through our conversation
you guys can start
thinking about a game plan
that makes sense for you and your life.
So Nathaniel, what do we
do about this problem?
- There is a lot we can do about it.
This is nowhere near a sort of situation
where it's like out of our control,
that's it, we live in a dystopia.
I'm seeing more and more
people wake up to this
and I find that very encouraging
and I have felt in myself
over the last year, particularly
because of the imbalances
that I feel in my life and in the world
that I am also making an
effort to not feel like
I'm at the mercy of this machine learning
that is deciding everything for me.
I do believe I have control
over this to a certain extent.
And if that means that at times I need
to remove myself from it or
change things up then, so be it.
But I have control over that.
- Right off the bat.
I love this point that Nathan makes,
my entire last video was about how having
an internal locus of control
is extremely important
when everything around us seems
to be so out of our control.
We can't control the pandemic.
We can't control the economy.
We can't control a lot in our lives
but we do have control over
our actions and our behaviors.
And I feel like social
media's influence on us
is a great example of something
that we have the power
to be proactive about.
- I think this is really
interesting, internal locus.
(beep) Yeah
- Yeah dude.
- If you're trying to break
out of an algorithmically controlled life,
I would say there's two things
to take into consideration.
One, there's a level of
personal accountability.
Take a level of ownership
over your decisions
and how you're spending your time.
Like there's no alternative
to that, you can.
There's no workaround,
but there's also a level
of understanding that helps me feel
a little bit more self-compassionate
in when I recognize
that, okay, I am
susceptible to distractions
and brightly colored
interesting looking thumbnails,
let's say.
And so, I take steps to
sort of remove it from
or add friction, right?
Like make it all a little
bit less accessible.
And I think it's been a process, dude.
I say this all the time.
I feel like I sound like a broken record
but I'm always trying things
out to see what works.
And it's been a multi-month,
multi-year process
of me trying to figure
out what is the life
that I want to live and what is the level
of information consumption
that is right for me.
I find I have to just check in
with myself regularly, constantly, almost.
- So if how we spend
our time is our choice
and we know that we probably
shouldn't be spending
as much time on social media,
I think it's really
important that we take out
a good old-fashioned pen
and paper and try to think
about how we would ideally
like to spend our day.
How much time do you wanna
be spending on social media?
And you know, maybe that's not zero.
Maybe you do wanna engage
in these like pleasures
a little bit, but be intentional with it.
Try to plan out how much
time you actually want
to be spending and be
conscious of that decision.
Otherwise, YouTube and Reddit
and Facebook are really good
at just stealing your time from you
if you don't have a plan.
And once you've made this plan,
once you've kind of designed
the structure around your social media use
I think there's a lot of tools.
I think Apple has one
if you have an iPhone,
Android has one if you have an Android
where you can actually
set timers certain apps.
I'd highly recommend you
look up a YouTube video on
how to set timers on apps
depending on what OS you have,
that'll add an element of friction
and help you stay on your goal.
Yeah, I think that's a really
like level headed approach
because I feel like so many
people they get so fed up
with all the control that social
media has over their lives
and they get very extreme about it.
So they'll like smash
their phone with a hammer
or like install like
blockers on their computer.
And they're like, Oh,
I'm deleting my Facebook.
I'm never going on any
of these apps again.
I'm retaking control of my
life, but I feel like 99%
of people who do that end up
kind of like bouncing back.
They underestimate the gravity of like
what this social media is
replacing in your life.
If you find yourself constantly
escaping from reality
then you need to work really
hard to create a reality
you don't want to from.
- It's easy to forget about this.
Being too externally focused,
thinking there's solutions
in terms of systems or
how I should live my life
or what I should be doing with my time
that will solve everything.
And that is the part of the equation
but it's not the whole thing.
To get to a place where
you're living a life
that you don't necessarily
wanna escape from,
there's an internal element,
I don't know if that makes sense.
It's sort of like, what is your
relationship with yourself.
- Yeah, I think a lot of
us use technology as a form
of escapism, which I can
totally relate to, by the way.
I know personally that,
especially in times like this
when I tried to just not spend all day
on Facebook or Instagram or even YouTube
sometimes an anxiety or discomfort
starts to stir within me
and it's very uncomfortable.
It actually feels almost
physically painful
to remove yourself from technology
and just have a more boring day
or at least a less stimulating day.
But I think it's extremely important
that we engage with
this side of ourselves.
I think it's extremely important
to really feel this boredom
and to feel this anxiety so
that we can actually work
through it and stop escaping
from it all the time.
And there are a couple
of things that you can do
to sort of properly work
through these emotions
and become a lot more
okay with being alone,
being cut off from this
constant flow of information.
One of my favorite ways of
doing that is mindfulness.
Learning how to just observe
your negative thoughts
from sort of a third person perspective
and also journaling, writing down things
that you're concerned about
and writing down a game plan
for how you might
overcome those obstacles.
And honestly, just get outside.
Get out of your house, go in nature.
There are safe ways to leave your house.
And I honestly think
that one of the best ways
to clear your head is to sort of reconnect
with that primal aspect of you.
Go outside, go for a walk
in nature, go for a hike,
exercise as much as possible.
There are ways that
you can spend time away
from social media apps that
are actually kind of fun
and will make you feel better.
- That's why I'm saying that
this period of a lockdown
and time alone, it was
painful and it was difficult
especially early last year,
but I'm really, really grateful
that I went through this because
it has completely shifted
how I spend time with myself.
And I think I kind of saw more clearly
than I've ever seen before
that it all starts from there.
So if I can't solve that
no matter what I try to do
any self-improvement sense
I will never get to that sort of lifestyle
that makes me feel like
I don't need to escape.
- Ultimately though, even
the fact that you're watching
this video hopefully
has caused you to think
about the role that you want social media
and the internet in general
to play in your lives.
And also be more cognizant of the fact
that a lot of these websites
that you like to spend time on
are profiting greatly from your attention.
They want to keep you hooked
into them as much as possible
even at the expense of your mental health
and your overall sense of wellbeing.
And hopefully all this will
help you spend your time
in a way that you want to be spending it
not how Lord Zucc wants you to spend it.
So as many of you guys know,
one of my favorite ways
to consume content without
any algorithm involved
is by listening to audio books
and by far, the easiest way to do that is
by using today's video sponsor, Audible.
And if you're looking for
something to listen to on Audible,
one of my favorite books of all time
in terms of just how helpful it was to me
is "Digital Minimalism" by Cal Newport.
And in this book, Cal
Newport really offers
so much insight as to what the entire goal
of big tech social media
companies actually is.
I had so many aha moments
and it really helped
me leverage technology
to help me achieve my goals
rather than keeping me a slave to it.
And for those of you who don't know,
Audible is the leading provider
of spoken word entertainment
and audio books ranging from bestsellers
to celebrity memoirs,
motivation, productivity
and so much more like
original entertainment
and even podcasts.
Audible recently launched
their newest plan Audible Plus
and with Audible Plus, you get access
to their entire plus
catalog, which is filled
with thousands and thousands
of select originals,
audio books, and podcasts,
including ad-free versions
of popular shows as well
as exclusive series.
Personally, one of my favorite
things about Audible is
that if you decide to cancel
your membership at any point
you still keep your entire
library of audio books
including the audio books
that you got for free
using their credit system.
So it's kind of a no brainer.
So to sign up for your free
30 day trial, click the link
in the description below,
visit audible.com/betterideas
or text better ideas to 500-500.
Once again, click the link
in the description below
or text better ideas to 500-500,
expand your mind, learn something new
and as usual have a great time.
So usually this is the part
of the video where I'm like,
if you like this video,
make sure you hit like
because when you hit like
the algorithm blesses me
and it shoves my bald head
into other people's
homepages helping them out
which also helps me out.
So it's a win-win for everybody.
But even just saying
that seems instinctually
counterproductive to what I just said.
I don't think it is as
counterproductive as I think it is
because people are gonna get a video
on their homepage no matter what.
So it might as well be a video
that's telling people to
think about how much time
they want to be spending on YouTube.
However, the next part,
if you're lurking here,
consider subscribing and
hitting the bell icon
so you don't miss future videos.
Yeah, let's scrap that.
You can subscribe if you want to
but really think about
whether you wanna be hitting
that bell icon on any YouTuber in general,
because I would hate to be the person
who interrupts a chess
game with your father
or a conversation with your grandma.
You know, me being like,
Hey, get off social media
and it's notification to tell
you to get off social media.
It's completely counterproductive.
Anyways, that's all for today.
Thank you so much for watching
and we'll catch you in the next video.